a really strange story out of a female
prison
this is a women's only prison in new
jersey
where two of the female inmates
were just impregnated
by one of the other female inmates now i
like as future supreme court justice
katanji jackson i am not a biologist
uh i suppose this could be miraculous or
there could be some development and by
or
oh right
right that female inmate is not really a
female
she is a he it's a dude who's pretending
to be a woman
who has now just knocked up two of the
inmates
this occurs
less than a year after the state began
to adopt
this new transgender theory into the
prison system
which places inmates in the system
uh in
based on their gender identity rather
than their actual sex
this story is going to be suppressed
because it
is just another example exposing the
transgender
uh
nonsense for what it is which is an
absurdity
this story apparently the the inmates
who were impregnated were impregnated
willingly
apparently that's not totally clear but
i think that's
generally what's being reported
but let's take it further
what is one of the main things that
occurs in prison
rape
rape it occurs so frequently in prison
that it's a joke
right the joke is hey you're going to
prison don't drop the soap hey you're
going to prison you better punch the
strongest guy in there because you're
going to be made somebody's girlfriend
you're going to be the girlfriend of
bubba when you go in there buddy right
this is a this is a joke in movies just
throughout our culture
and
it i guess it's bad enough when we're
talking about single sex prisons
but now let's say you've got hardened
crim male criminals
going into female prisons
it's a little less funny isn't it it's a
little more
so it's a lot more jarring
well this could never happen they tell
us that you're just arguing about some
slippery slope now of course it's not
only is this stuff going to happen it is
happening now so what is your absurd
false gender ideology worth to you is it
worth lots of prisoners well one getting
knocked up that creates a huge problem
in and of itself think about these poor
kids these poor kids are now going to be
born to women in prison it's a horrible
situation for the women and for the kids
or the kids are going to be killed
through abortion
or they're going to be sent into the
foster care system this is a horrible
situation
that was only that only exists now
because of the absurd selfish sexual
theories of radical degenerates who are
running our country
so that shouldn't happen period
what's it worth to you is it worth is
your radical crazy sexual theory worth
getting women raped
because that's what's happening
that's what's going to happen of course
we know actually that a a transgender
bathroom policy in loudoun county led to
multiple rapes of young girls
we know that
is it worth that to you what the left
would say is yes
that's we know they would say that
because they know the risks and they're
pushing the stuff anyway can't make an
omelette without breaking a few eggs and
the omelet i guess is having men dress
up like women did you like that clip
good i'm glad ring that bell subscribe
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcast but if i stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you